♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN TALKING
POINT OR REALLY ANY KIND OF
EXAGGERATION AT ALL TO SAY THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS OPENED THIS
COUNTRY 'HAS BORDERS TO THE
WORLD.
SINCE BIDEN'S INAUGURATION IN
JANUARY, THE BORDER PATROL HAS
APPREHENDED CLOSE TO A MILLION
FOREIGN NATIONALS COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY OVERLAND THROUGH
MEXICO.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IS THAT?
WELL, IT'S MORE PEOPLE THAN LIVE
IN THE ENTIRE CITIES OF
SAN FRANCISCO, OR DENVER, OR
SEATTLE, OR INDIANAPOLIS, OR
BOSTON, OR CHARLOTTE, AND WE
COULD KEEP GOING.
THAT'S ALL IN JUST SIX MONTHS.
IT IS ENOUGH PEOPLE TO CHANGE
THIS COUNTRY FOREVER.
THEY MAY ARGUE THAT'S A GOOD
THING, AMERICA WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS MASS INFLUX OF NEW PEOPLE
FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
IF SO, WE'D LOVE TO HEAR THAT
ARGUMENT IN DETAIL.
NO ONE SO FAR HAS EXPLAINED HOW
THAT WORKS.
BUT WHAT YOU CAN'T ARGUE IS THAT
OPENING THE BORDERS WAS LEGAL OR
THAT ANYONE IN THIS COUNTRY
VOTED FOR IT.
THE CURRENT MASS MOVEMENT OF
FOREIGN NATIONALS INTO THE
UNITED STATES WAS NEVER APPROVED
BY CONGRESS.
NO ONE PASSED A LAW DEMANDING
IT.
THE BIKE DEMONSTRATION JUST DID
IT UNILATERALLY WITHOUT ASKING
AMERICANS WHAT THEY THOUGHT OF
IT.
THEY PROBABLY ALREADY KNEW.
EVERY POLL WE'VE EVER SEEN SHOWS
CLEARLY THAT VOTERS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS OPPOSE OPEN BORDERS.
THAT POLICY IS HIGHLY UNPOPULAR.
THE ADMINISTRATION COULDN'T SAY
OUT LOUD WHAT THEY WERE DOING,
INSTEAD THEY OPERATED IN
SECRECY, THEY HID IT.
SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE THEY DOING?
TONIGHT WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION
FOR YOU THAT ANSWERS THAT
QUESTION, AT LEAST IN PART.
THIS SHOW HAS CONFIRMED THAT THE
BIDEN OF ADMINISTRATION HAS
ENLISTED THE U.S. MILITARY TO
MOVE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SECRETLY
AROUND OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS HAPPENING UP IN
AIR FORCE BASE IN TEXAS.
WE KNOW IT'S HAPPENING THERE
BECAUSE A MAN CALLED LIEUTENANT
COLONEL MATTHEW BURROUGHS SENT
TO SUBORDINATES AND EMAIL
SPELLING OUT VERY CLEARLY.
"OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS, WEEKS,
OR MONTHS," THE NOTE BEGAN, "YOU
MAY SEE PASSENGER AIRCRAFT ON A
RAMP TRANSPORTING UNDOCUMENTED
CITIZENS.
PLEASE REVIEW THE ATTACHED
GUIDANCE ON THE ISSUE."
THE EMAIL THEN INSTRUCTED
UNIFORMED MILITARY PERSONNEL TO
HIDE WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON THE
BASE FROM THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
SWORN TO SERVE.
"DO NOT TAKE PHOTOGRAPHS AND
REFRAIN FROM POSTING ANYTHING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA."
LIEUTENANT COLONEL BURROUGHS
OFFERED NO NATIONAL SECURITY
JUSTIFICATION FOR KEEPING ANY OF
THIS SECRET
BECAUSE THERE IS NO
NATIONAL SECURITY
JUSTIFICATION FOR KEEPING IT
FROM THE REST OF US.
HE JUST TOLD THE PEOPLE WHO
WORKED FOR HIM NOT TO TALK.
WE GOT HIS EMAIL FROM A
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND A FIRST WE
DOUBTED IT COULD BE REAL.
DURING THE LAST OF
ADMINISTRATION, THE PANIC ON
FIRMLY REFUSED TO PROTECT
AMERICA'S SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT'S NOT OUR JOB, THEY SAID,
IT'S TOO POLITICAL, SEND IT TO
SYRIA, YES ACCORDING TO THIS
DOCUMENT HERE WAS THE VERY SAME-
HELPING THE BIDEN A
ADMINISTRATION WITH MAXIMUM
ENFORCED STEALTH, WITH SECRECY,
TO SUBVERT THE CORE IMMIGRATION
LAWS OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT WAS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
COULD BE HAPPENING, BUT IT IS
HAPPENING.
THE PENTAGON HAS CONFIRMED IT TO
US.
SPOKESMAN CHRIS MITCHELL
DESCRIBED THE FLIGHTS FROM
LOUGHLIN NONCITIZEN MOVEMENT,
PART OF WHAT HE CALLED THE U.S.
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOM
ENFORCEMENT'S ADMISSION.
HE TOLD US THEN TO DIRECT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS TO ICE.
SO WE DID, WE CALLED ICE
MULTIPLE TIMES.
ICE DID NOT DENY THEY WERE USING
THE AIR FORCE BASE TO RELOCATE
LARGE NUMBERS OF FOREIGN
NATIONALS INTO THE INTERIOR OF
OUR COUNTRY AND DO IT SECRETLY.
THE QUESTION IS, WHERE ARE ALL
THESE PEOPLE GOING?
SEVERAL TIMES ICE PROMISED US
ADDITIONAL DETAILS BUT IN THE
END WE NEVER HEARD BACK.
APPARENTLY AMERICANS DO NOT HAVE
A RIGHT TO KNOW WHERE FOREIGN
NATIONALS ARE BEING SETTLED IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
WE DO KNOW, THANKS TO THE CENTER
FOR IMMIGRATION STUDIES THAT THE
A ADMINISTRATION, THE BIDEN A
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN SENDING
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES FOR SOME TIME NOW.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING MOST OF THE
TIME IS THAT THEY ARE BOARDING
BUSES AND HEADING INTO AMERICA'S
HEARTLAND.
A CONVEYOR BELT OF COMMERCIAL
AND CHARTER BUSES JUST LIKE THIS
ONE IN DEL RIO, TEXAS, ARE
CARRYING TENS OF THOUSANDS,
SIGHT UNSEEN, FROM TEXAS,
ARIZONA, CALIFORNIA BORDERLANDS
NORTHWARD AND THEY ARE DROPPING
THEIR HAITIAN, VENEZUELAN,
CUBAN, AND CENTRAL AMERICAN
FAMILY UNITS IN FLORIDA AND
NEW JERSEY, TENNESSEE,
MASSACHUSETTS, MICHIGAN,
NORTH CAROLINA, GEORGIA,
KENTUCKY, AND TWO LARGE CITIES
IN TEXAS SUCH AS DALLAS AND
HOUSTON.
>> Tucker: OH, CHANGING THE
ELECTORAL MAP, ARE WE?
SERVING THE BUSINESSES THAT PAID
FOR YOU TO GET ELECTED ARE WE?
YES WE ARE.
THOSE ARE BUSES YOU JUST SAW.
NOW THAT ADMINISTRATION IS USING
AIRCRAFT AND AIR FORCE BASES AND
THAT OUGHT TO GIVE YOU SOME
SENSE OF THE SCALE INVOLVED
HERE.
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING IS
DEMOGRAPHIC TRANSFORMATION.
IN OUR COUNTRY, WITHOUT OUR
CONSENT AND IN VIOLATION OF OUR
LAWS.
THAT IS HAPPENING.
OUR JOB IS TO SHUT UP AND ACCEPT
IT.
WE NOTE THEY WILL CALL US NAMES
IF WE DON'T ACCEPT IT, BUT NO
THANKS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING, WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, IS WRONG.
IT IS, MOREOVER, A VIOLATION OF
THE MOST AND BASIC PROMISE OF
DEMOCRACY, WHICH IS THAT
CITIZENS GET TO CONTROL WHO RUNS
THE GOVERNMENT.
WE AS CITIZENS HAVE